Margot Robbie is making moves and we  haven't seen the last of Harley Quinn  Robbie just signed a first-look deal  with Warner Brothers that means she will  not only be acting but producing films  for the studio through her production  company lucky chap entertainment the  contract is said to be a continued push  from Warner Brothers to focus on female  driven storytelling content the New Deal  has margo starring in a Suicide Squad  spin-off as well as taking on the role  of executive producer it's been rumored  that Batgirl and birds of prey could  make appearances in this Harley Quinn  flip and we all know when we see Harley  the Joker isn't far behind I think we  can all agree that we want to see more  of dr. Harleen Quinzel and her antics on  the big screen